Vapor teeny is a device that lets people
inhale alcohol and this parasite eats
the tongue the fishhooks itself into the
muscles of the tongue stub and becomes
its new tongue Vsauce Kevin here this is
mine
this DNA gun invisibly tracks criminals
for weeks
developed by UK based companies select a
mark the high-velocity DNA tagging
system fires small soft green pellets
kind of like a paintball filled with a
unique DNA code that can penetrate
clothing and mark a suspects skin
the idea is to mark criminals during a
riot so they can be arrested later when
the DNA tag is revealed using a UV light
the hostile plot Nair Institute in
Potsdam Germany has an interactive floor
that creates a computer-generated
reflection of you the video screen floor
is touch sensitive and the system uses
infrared camera and high resolution
projector it tracks footsteps in beams
video up to the glass the hope is that
this technology eventually leads to new
ways of playing games
controlling objects in the home or
assisting disabled people the chemical
and biomolecular engineering department
at NC State University has developed
self-healing stretchable wires the wire
is made of a gallium liquid metal alloy
and a self-healing polymer that heals it
both mechanically and electrically after
being severed with scissors dear diary
today's I made a desk with a pillow on
it so as I can sleeps on my desk yeah
engineers in Taiwan are developing
displays for fingertips the point is to
still be able to see the display on your
smartphone or tablet while your thumb is
obscuring it it even enlarges the view
so it's easier to tap small buttons on a
two and a half centimeter diagonal o LED
screen and you can also see and answer
incoming calls with it the artificial
photosynthesis system is being developed
by Panasonic and is producing organic
materials with the efficiency of real
plants used in biomass energy it uses
sunlight to produce oxygen from water
and carbon dioxide and they hope to use
this to solve global warming and energy
problems find the link below for more
kilobots our tiny cheap robots that are
being used to research swarm algorithms
designed by a research group at Harvard
that cost about $14 each our 33
millimeters in diameter and can
communicate
Kait with neighbors up to 7 centimeters
now let's just watch them swarm for a
second
the University of Southern California
did a real-time MRI study of human
beatboxing this allows researchers to
visualize the movement of the vocal
tract from the upper trachea to the lips
and the opening and closing of the vocal
folds to help study the mechanisms that
produce various sounds finally the
Monterey Bay Aquarium has a great video
of the lobed comb jelly which has comb
rows that diffract light as they swim
I'm gonna leave you with sperm from two
males competing within the reproductive
tract of a female fruit fly seriously
and as always thanks for watching
I have such a large selection of
crackers in my grocery store it's a mind
blow wait what's a mind blow ah I've
been waiting for you Vsauce Darth Vader
why are you working in a grocery store
I'm Chad Vader
that'll work here I rule here as day
shift manager click here to check out
the latest season of Chad Vader and as
always and as always thanks for choosing
the Dark Soul half